[Music]
[Applause]
mike florio pro football talk live
co-host you sure you want to be part of
this mike i'm enjoying it i like
listening to it but and it's all
accurate and you know what i think i
heard that hub arkis isn't voting for
aaron rodgers for mvp because he can't
get the rogers oh he can't get the
rogers no you get the rogers wrath is
what you get
and you've and you've felt that before
with uh aaron rodgers
not like hub artist did yesterday
it's always nice when it happens to
someone other than you uh what did you
think of what
okay what did you have a problem with
with hub orcish
well i have a problem with
completely twisted and warped reasoning
for not
voting for aaron rodgers for mvp it's
about what you do on the field from week
one to week 18. not what you did in the
off season not what you said in the
preseason not whether or not you were
vaccinated not whether or not you lied
about being vaccinated and i said at the
time that he missed that key game
against the chiefs and they lost
if this costs them the number one seed
in the nfc it will cost him the mvp if
the bucks are the one seed tom brady's
going to be the mvp but the packers
nailed down the one seed rogers numbers
were phenomenal there's no way he's not
the mvp and withholding the vote for any
other reason is wrong and hub arkansas
shouldn't have one of the votes i've
asked the ap is he still going to have
one of the votes because they haven't
cast the ballots yet they should strip
it away from him and all he's apologized
for dan is saying it out loud he hasn't
apologized for having improper
motivation so he was flat out wrong and
it was refreshing to see so many people
set aside whatever concerns they may
have about aaron rodgers and point out
that hub arkish was wrong to believe
what he believes as he plans to cast his
ballot it's been an interesting season
for aaron rodgers because that seems and
the offseason it feels like there's been
this roller coaster ride of
hey we support him
we don't support him he lied to us
deceived us man he's playing great to
you know the packers are screwing them
up whatever it is it feels like it's
just been this unbelievable ride but i
come back to the same bottom line mike
if you play in that division
you have devonta adams
and you have an organization that is a
really good organization with draft
picks except for jordan love
why would you leave
why would aaron rodgers leave
you're absolutely right and that's
something sims and i have been kicking
around on pft live in the mornings the
idea that
he runs that division
it's the worst division in football but
for the presence of the packers where do
you go
where else do you go in the nfl where
you slip right in
and you have a great team around you
that can dominate you know the broncos
of the team he's been linked to okay
fine have fun with the chiefs and
patrick holmes have fun with the
chargers and justin herbert have fun in
the afc which has plenty of other great
teams you are in a great spot to keep
winning with tom brady it was a
no-brainer the patriots talent was
declining he had a perfect opportunity
in tampa bay where they had a good team
all they needed was a quarterback and it
worked out so i think rogers should stay
where he is and frankly dan i think that
from roger's perspective it all comes
down to the next move the packers make
financially do they come to him and say
you know we're paying you 33.5 million
dollars a year that's the same jared
goff is making we know what the market
is you don't even need to ask
for a raise they should come to him and
put him somewhere between 40 and 45
million a year with a full guarantee for
two or three years invalidate the jordan
love pick trade jordan love or keep
until the end of his contract either way
rogers is your guy that's what the
packers need to do next and i think if
they do that i think rogers would be
very inclined to stay
there's a report that just came out
seton do you have that from mary kay
cabot who covers the cleveland browns
you know cleveland plain dealer uh has
to do with baker mayfield uh do you have
the exact language on that scene you
know i don't have the exact language in
front of me but she basically said that
unless there were reassurances given to
him for next season that he would ask to
be traded
trade him trade him bye-bye that's it i
got no problem with it and i had a
feeling it was going this way
they need to do soul-searching about who
their quarterback is
and part of the other equation is he may
want out and i've had a feeling all
along it was going to come to this so
no
baker you haven't been good enough to
make demands tom brady can make demands
aaron rodgers can make demands russell
wilson can make demands baker you
haven't done enough to make demands if
this is going to be they're better off
moving on from it
and you start to look at
you know when you have these musical
chairs with these quarterbacks in the
offseason let's say roger stays
so denver's in in the market um
cleveland will be in the market i don't
know if the dolphins are still in the
market i guess they will be
uh you can throw carolina in there
there's a washington football team
there's only so many quality
quarterbacks are going to be available
and i don't know if any of these draft
picks are a draft me now when i play
right away
how do you see this
scenario playing out in the offseason
well the first step is what happens with
the coaches because i think that has a
huge influence on decisions that are
made about quarterbacks and quarterbacks
making decisions about where they want
to go starting with russell wilson if
pete carroll stays as the head coach of
the seahawks he's more likely to want to
move on if they move on from carol and
they hire a guy that russell wilson
looks at and says well this guy's going
to rejuvenate my career and help me get
to the three super bowls that he openly
said last week he aspires to win i mean
unless he's going to play until he's 80
he better find himself in a spot where
he's more likely to win super bowls
sooner rather than later so the coaching
carousel is going to drive it
and you know we're seeing this every
year now dan i think because teams
have become willing to let the bird in
the hand go the quarterback who's just
good enough okay it's fine we have a guy
who's just good enough but we can do
better and we're going to try to do
better and you see a greater willingness
from teams to say we're willing to part
with the guy we have
in the hopes of finding someone
better the carolina panthers are the
epitome of that right now they
desperately want a franchise quarterback
they threw out teddy bridgewater they're
gonna throw out sam darnold they're
gonna throw out cam newton and they keep
looking for better and i think a lot of
teams feel that way yeah i just wonder
if you could see a scenario where
russell wilson leaves goes to cleveland
yes absolutely because absolutely and i
think they have a style that is
reminiscent of what russ had when they
had the legion of boom where you had a
good running game but you you could let
him cook now as we like to say uh maybe
baker mayfield ends up in new orleans
chris sims brought that up the other day
uh you know deshawn watson denver
miami
carolina
i'm not sure but you know it feels like
that you know when you start to look at
somebody's going to get left out
and and it you know is it denver do i
want to go into the afc west
uh you know what i as we just you know
pointed out uh carolina are they gonna
get it right this time do the dolphins
upgrade from tua have they seen enough
of tua good or bad so i i don't know
it's always fascinating um you know the
reality show that is the nfl
i think i got to move on from tua and i
know that we're very careful about
activating two and on they are very loud
they are very vocal and they're very
loyal but just watch some of the low
lights
from the week 17 game against the titans
including the brucy from the longest
yard moment where his arm goes this way
the ball goes that way
he's good enough that's the thing
are you tolerating good enough or do you
want great and it's clear that stephen
ross the owner of the team wants great
and they've seen enough from tour to
come to that conclusion dan one team you
didn't mention that i think is going to
be fascinating when it comes to these
dynamics of offseason quarterbacks the
steelers
what are they going to do because it
can't be mason rudolph no and dwayne
haskins is buried on the depth chart he
hasn't done enough to supplant mason
rudolph so it tells me they're going to
be looking somewhere for someone to step
in and that's an attractive landing spot
for an established veteran quarterback
because they got the defense they got
the coaching remember the googly eyes
between aaron rodgers and mike thompson
i know
when they played you know aaron rodgers
is looking for greener grass not that
it's very green in pittsburgh this time
of year but boy that's a spot where he
should at least be wondering how would
it go for me if i could land there yeah
teddy bridgewater probably end up there
this was this was treated as breaking
news yesterday
and wfaa in dallas you know that now we
have another site in case the super bowl
can't be played in los angeles and i
thought
is this breaking news are they saying
the super bowl's not in los angeles
this is standard procedure isn't it mike
well i think the trigger was the
postponement of the grammys on january
31 in la that's what got people starting
to connect dots and say what are the
contingencies and since then someone
from the la county governmental
structure has come out and said the
super bowl is happening here so uh you
know there's a thought that this is all
going to peak and begin to subside not
that anybody cares that's the other side
of it if anybody cared it would be
different we're at the point where we're
past it we're over whether that's right
or wrong it doesn't matter that's where
we are i'd be stunned at this point if
the super bowl gets moved and if it does
it's not something they can wait until a
week before the game it's a fairly
urgent uh situation especially for the
folks at nbc who are broadcasting the
game to know you know where is our
operation going to be is it going to be
in california is it going to be in texas
or somewhere else okay is there anything
that could happen
where we would need contingency plans
that the super bowl would move to dallas
unless that there's you know some new
variant that is even more transmissible
but far more
problematic from the symptoms it causes
and the serious illnesses it creates it
would take something like that but we're
talking about five weeks away i think
that the current belief is the omicron
variant is going to begin to dip and the
cloud's going to part at least for a
little bit and we'll be able to get this
done but but who knows but they do but
dan you're right they have contingency
plans every year yeah just in case
something would come up that would keep
a game from moving forward if you were
antonio brown's agent and you being a
lawyer so let's factor that in as well
what would be your course of action
well
my my first guy would be to fire antonio
brown frankly because he's clearly not
following the advice
that they're giving him because i'm sure
they said to him
stay off social media let's have no
let's have no outbursts
let's let's lay low here and see how
this plays out look dan i can't figure
this out for the life of me because
if the story from antonio brown's camp
is his ankle is sufficiently injured
that he needs surgery and he's done for
the season
why won't the buccaneers just release
him and why is brown's camp complaining
about and the hashtag is cut and caged
they're cutting him but they haven't cut
him they're keeping in a cage well it's
not like he can go anywhere else in play
because he's got an ankle injury that
needs surgery that knocks him out for
the season i think the buccaneers
haven't released him because there's
that sliver of fear that somebody's
gonna have to explain to tom brady why
it was and antonio brown had 10 catches
for 152 yards and two touchdowns in the
game that knocked the buccaneers out of
the playoffs up to and including super
bowl 56 if he would land with the chiefs
which i think would be the first team i
would watch as a potential destination
so that's where the logic falls apart if
he can't play due to the ankle
why won't the buccaneers just cut him
we're at the end of the season it just
cut him cut him and if wherever he lands
he lands especially if he can't play so
i don't know what to believe i think
everyone's at fault i think it's a huge
mess it's great for business but it's
not great for the buccaneers or for
antonio brown and i wouldn't want to
have anything to do with it as an agent
as a lawyer as anyone it's too big of a
mess right now
uh let me leave you with this and this
is a curveball um
why isn't dan reeves in the pro football
hall of fame
well he will be and i'll tell you i'll
tell you why now in the past
there was too much competition with
players for coaches to get in as
frequently as they should get in they've
created this separate track now
that makes it easier for coaches to get
in and we're going to see the backlog of
coaches who should have gotten in
starting with tom flores most recently
guys who will get in who should have
been in all along and you're going to
clear out that backlog of coaches who
should have been in but i think the
problem is and it makes it remarkable
when a guy like tony dungy does it when
you emerge as one of the finalists and
one of the
ultimate recipients of the bronze bust
when you're competing with quarterbacks
running backs linemen players it's
harder to compete with players they've
made it easier so reeves will get in
yeah i look at the resume as a player as
an assistant coach as a head coach and
yes he did lose those super bowls but
man
i think tom brady's the only guy who's
been to more super bowls than dan reeves
if if that sounds right and the
challenge is how do you categorize dan
reeves because they always like to have
a category and sometimes the things you
do beyond that category help you get in
it helped john madden get in
it helped dick lebeau get in his time as
a coach helped him get in as a player
but i don't like the categorization it
should be your full contribution to
football and dan reeves did more than
enough that he should get in and he will
get in he will get in because of the way
they've tweaked the rules within the
next i don't know three four five years
he'll be in good
great to talk to you again mike thank
you all right dan thanks mike florio pro
football talk live co-host and
contributor to football night in america